[Music]
what do fans of atmospheric post-punk
music have in common with ancient
barbarians not much so why are both
known as Goths is it a weird coincidence
or a deeper connection stretching across
the centuries the story begins in
ancient Rome as the Roman Empire
expanded it faced raids and invasions
from the semi-nomadic populations along
its borders among the most powerful were
a Germanic people known as Goths who
were composed of two tribal groups the
Visigoths and Ostrogoths while some of
the Germanic tribes remained Rome's
enemies the Empire incorporated others
into the Imperial Army as the Roman
Empire split in two these tribal armies
played larger roles in its defence and
internal power struggles in the fifth
century a mercenary revolt led by a
soldier named odo icer captured Rome and
deposed the western Emperor Otto I sir
and his Ostrogoths successor Theodoric
technically remained under the eastern
Emperor's Authority and maintained Roman
traditions but the Western Empire would
never be united again its dominions
fragmented into kingdoms ruled by Goths
and other Germanic tribes who
assimilated into local cultures though
many of their names still mark the map
this was the end of the Classical period
and the beginning of what many call the
Dark Ages
although Roman culture was never fully
lost its influence declined and new art
styles arose focused on religious
symbolism and allegory rather than
proportion and realism this shift
extended to architecture with the
construction of the abbey of San Denis
in France in 1137 pointed arches flying
buttresses and large windows made the
structure more skeletal and orny that
emphasized its open luminous interior
rather than the sturdy walls and Kalla
of classical buildings over the next few
centuries this became a model for
cathedrals throughout Europe but
fashions change with the Italian
Renaissance as renewed admiration for
ancient Greece and Rome the more recent
style began to seem crude and inferior
in comparison writing in his 1550 book
lives of the artists Giorgio Vasari
was the first to describe it as gothic a
derogatory reference to the barbarians
thought to have destroyed classical
civilization the name stuck and soon
came to describe the medieval period
overall with its associations of
darkness superstition and simplicity but
time marched on as did what was
considered fashionable in the 1700s a
period called the Enlightenment came
about which valued scientific reason
above all else reacting against that
Romantic authors like Goethe and Byron
sought idealized visions of a past of
natural landscapes and mysterious
spiritual forces hear the word gothic
was repurposed again to describe a
literary genre that emerged as a darker
strain of Romanticism the term was first
applied by Horace Walpole to his own
1764 novel the Castle of Otranto as a
reference to the plot and general
atmosphere many of the novel's elements
became genres staples inspiring classics
and the countless movies they spawned
the gothic label belonged to literature
and film until the 1970s when a new
musical scene emerged taking cues from
artists like The Doors and The Velvet
Underground British post-punk groups
like Joy Division Bauhaus and The Cure
combined gloomy lyrics and Punk
dissonance with imagery inspired by the
Victorian era classic horror and
androgynous glam fashion by the early
1980s similar bands were consistently
described as gothic rock by the music
press and the Styles popularity
brought it out of dimly lit clubs
to major labels and MTV and today
despite occasional negative media
attention and stereotypes gothic music
and fashion continue as a strong
underground phenomenon
they've also branched into sub genres
such as cybergoth Gotha villi gothic
metal and even steampunk the history of
the word gothic is embedded in thousands
of years worth of countercultural
movements from invading Outsiders
becoming kings to towering spires
replacing solid columns to artists
finding beauty in darkness each step has
seen a revolution of sorts and a
tendency for civilization to reach into
its past to reshape its present
you
[Music]